[Musik]
montags in brackenheim schwäbische
provinz 2000 sind in der kleinstadt auf
den beinen
der berliner journalist thomas moser ist
hier geboren bereits 2020 gab es die
ersten proteste es gibt so viele leute
die sind nicht einfach die warten jetzt
nicht nur ob es klappt oder nicht jeder
lässt sich brav impfen und hoffe es
klappt sondern sie sagen nein es wird
nicht klar
ein spot des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums die
impfung wird als schritt in die freiheit
angepriesen die millionenteuren
werbebilder hielten nicht was sie
versprachen auch geimpfte stecken sich
an
pleitegegangene geschäfte brackenheim
ächzt ein beliebtes café zog
konsequenzen
wir weisen keine gesunden oder ungeübten
gäste aus unserem café befördern nicht
die diskriminierung und weitere spaltung
unserer gesellschaft riss geht auch
zusagen durch die darauf gesellschaft er
geht durch die familien ergeht es ihr
euch freundeskreis er geht durch den
sportverein sichtbare neonazis angriffe
auf die presse gibt es in brackenheim
nicht der protest scheint hier aus der
mitte zu kommen das wird sozusagen zum
politischen faktor und damit zur gefahr
so die regierenden in gewisser weise und
darauf reagieren die jetzt jetzt ist der
zeitpunkt da wo auch die ungeimpften mal
ihren beitrag leisten müssen und das ist
aus meiner sicht
immer dringlicher werden die forderungen
der politik nach einer impfpflicht
eine offene abstimmung im bundestag
haben werden über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht kirsten kappert konnte ist
stellvertretende vorsitzende des
gesundheitsausschusses eine impfpflicht
sei sinnvoll nicht nur medizinisch ich
erhoffe mir dass wir tatsächlich eine
gesellschaftliche befriedung auch
bekommen weil wir haben jetzt ja eine
situation wo diese frage wirklich sehr
sehr
individualisiert wird auch im sinne von
gegenseitigen abwertungen vor ein paar
monaten sagen dass die
regierungsparteien noch anders schlossen
die impfpflicht aus natürlich wissen wir
alle dass eine nebenpflicht also nicht
durchsetzbar wäre und bin gegen die
impfpflicht es wäre falsch auch kirsten
kappa dazu nun will sie eine impfpflicht
mit beratungsgesprächen flankieren
im gespräch noch mal geschulte profis
diesen menschen zur verfügung stellen
das könnten auch
psychotherapeutinnen sein müssen es aber
nicht um diesen menschen eben zu
ermöglichen noch mal zu reflektieren wo
ihre ängste liegen
psychotherapeuten die bürgerinnen die
pflicht nahebringen für demokratie
forscherin ulrike büro ein graus diese
hochgradige pathologisierung werden ich
glaub was der staat möchte was wir
glauben sollen ist natürlich muss das
sagen aber tendenziell totalitär also es
war tatsächlich im real existierenden
sozialismus in der udssr so dass jeder
der nicht an den sozialismus glauben
wollte wurde psychisch krank erklärt ja
es hat sich viel verschoben im land ein
minister del kinder vor dem pressehaus
impft regieren durch bilder
jetzt geht es um den politischen zugriff
auf den körper aber der körper ist doch
eigentlich meine würde und man
individuum und der ist tabu und zwar
ganz egal ob es um mein bauch geht oder
um den pieks so bis heute zumindestens
war der körper die grenze der
solidarität kohl regierung lehnt die
impfpflicht ab der staat verstieße mit
ihr gegen das grundgesetz und das recht
auf körperliche unversehrtheit schon mal
der impfstoff immer noch eine note
zulassung unterliege hinterfragen sei
auch in einer pandemie existenziell der
hegemoniale diskurs hat sich jetzt eben
festgelegt dass alles was gemacht wurde
vernünftig war bisher deswegen weiter
gemacht werden muss und dass es
eigentlich nur eine lösung gibt und das
ist die impfung und jetzt die booster
impfung und daneben die impfpflicht ja
dazu würde ich sagen dass in einer
demokratie eigentlich die eine lösung
auch nicht dass demokratische element
ist malte tiefen sieht die derzeitigen
diskussionen in historischer perspektive
menschen zu einer impfung zu
verpflichten dass er antiquiertes
staatliches vorgehen das erst mal war
ich erstaunt weil eigentlich in
historische perspektive die impfpflicht
passiva die impfpflicht ist nicht
unbedingt eine erfolgsgeschichte die hat
er schwere nebenwirkungen die für
massive probleme immer wieder gesorgt
haben im buch des medizinhistoriker kann
man lesen dass eine impfpflicht selten
dazu führt dass die impfquote deutlich
steigt so wurden im deutschen
kaiserreich massenhaft impfpässe
gefälscht hunderttausende gegner
organisierten sich eine impfpflicht
passe zu einem obrigkeitsstaat weniger
in eine demokratie die impfpflicht die
letztlich sozusagen von oben zum glück
zwingt stellt eigentlich alle menschen
unter generalverdacht
ihr seid so blöd oder nicht unten nicht
willig genug sozusagen sich impfen zu
lassen die bundesrepublik setzte wie bei
der schluckimpfung auf freiwilligkeit
fuhr gute mit quoten von 90 prozent
waren die regel doch nun die pflicht das
ist tatsächlich eine zäsur weil wir
gerade in der bundesrepublik seit den
60er jahren die selbstbestimmung des
patienten als ein sehr hohes gut gesehen
haben und sich das durchsetzt
es ist ein langer lernprozess oder damit
einhergeht dass wir selbst bestimmte
bürger sind die sozusagen für das
allgemeinwohl aber eben nicht blindlings
alles machen andreas lob hüdepohl ist
mitglied des deutschen ethikrats der
berät die bundesregierung und sprach
sich jüngst für eine impfpflicht aus der
katholische theologe hält sie allen
bedenken zum trotz für unproblematisch
dass ein staat das recht hat auch in die
körperliche unversehrtheit 1 vergaben
also erstens tut er das permanent die
gesellschaft tut das permanent ich bin
permanent
etwa der verschmutzung der luft des
wassers und dergleichen ausgesetzt das
heißt wie stehen selbst mit unserem
körper immer in einem politischen
zusammenhang ob ich das will oder nicht
die impfpflicht müsse kommen so lob
hüdepohl
medizinisch aber auch gesellschaftlich
damit sie gelinge brauche es dann aber
auch einen staat der sie durch setzte es
muss auch weh tun und
es ist überhaupt nichts ausgeschlossen
dass man eine solche ordnung gebühr
deutlich staffelt wenn ich schwarz
gefahren bin mehrfach und kann das nicht
bezahlen muss ja in haft ja 300 400
personen betrifft das gerade in berlin
zum beispiel nicht da gibt es ja
instrumente die müssen allerdings auch
angewandt werden die demonstranten von
braten
werden sie einer impfpflicht folgen
[Musik]